this episode's brought to you by
Squarespace the place to build a website
if you need one for your brand your
business or honestly for whatever more
about them in just a bit
the decades following the dissolution of
the Western Roman Empire were a Time
marked by chaos constant Warfare and
religious conflict but they were also a
time in which young ambitious leaders
and small up star kingdoms could aspire
to forge an Empire of their own these
leaders would naturally resort to
violence even against their own kin
whilst seeking support from Bishops and
Saints in the words of Professor Paul
Friedman of Yale University it was a
time of thugs and miracles in today's
video we're going to chart the rise to
the top of one of these alleged Thugs
and how through a series of alleged
Miracles he created the first
incarnation of a state that would
dominate European politics for centuries
this is the story of Clovis the first
king of the Franks and founding father
of France
[Music]
so let me start by giving you some
context today's protagonist was born to
chillarick the first and bassina king
and queen of the Salient Franks probably
in the year 466 A.D but who were the
Salient Franks and who were the pranks
the Franks were a Germanic speaking
people settled in what are today
Northwestern Germany the Benelux
countries and Northeastern France in the
first half of the 5th Century 80 the
Franks living west of the Rhine started
migrating further west and south
effectively invading the Western Roman
Empire these Western francs became known
as the Salient Franks and their leaders
would become allies of Rome and fight as
generals against enemies of the Empire
the Salient Franks were not a United
National entity however as they were
split into small kingdoms one of these
centered around Tornai modern-day
Belgium was led by King marive who had
fought the Huns alongside Roman general
atheists maribek was the initiator of
the dynasty later known as the
maravingians at bloodline which would
rule over France until the 8th century
when he died around 458 he was succeeded
by his son chidurik in 466 chitorik and
basina welcomed their firstborn son
later followed by three daughters Aldo
fleda lentheshield and Alba fledder for
their only son the king and queen went
for a proper masculine name horowick
this can be translated as renowned in
battle the name was rendered as
hodavakis in Latin and later historians
simplified it to Clovis but the same
name adopted different Regional variants
morphing into Ludwig or Lewis a name
which will become very popular with
French Kings confused great you should
be so let's simplify things by just
calling the boy Clovis shall we now we
don't know very much about his early
years but we know that Franks taught
their boys to fight from a very early
age in fact archaeologists have found
several tombs of salient children as
young as five being buried with weapons
now we could also speculate that generic
may have trained Clovis to become a
ruler and a military leader from an
early age therefore the pre-teen Clovis
may have been aware of the tumultuous
events that had been shaking the Western
Roman Empire at the age of 10 in the
year 476 he may have heard the news of
how Romulus or gustless The Last Emperor
had been overthrown and in later years
his father may have explained to him how
the dissolved Western Empire had been
carved into smaller kingdoms led by
people such as the alimani the
burgundians the ostrogoths assaxons the
basigarths and even their fellow Franks
east of the Rhine the ripporian Franks
these new polities all are far from
friendly and in fact chidrick had to
defend his Salient Kingdom against
visigoth and Saxon incursions alas
chitrick did not have much time to teach
her his son as he died in 481. turick
was buried in Tornai alongside 15 horses
weapons gold and jewelry as does with it
a King Clovis barely 15 years old
succeeded him on the throne but the
young Frank was already politically
Savvy and he knew that his authority at
such a young age could easily be
questioned at his father's funeral he
took the occasion to shower the top
military leaders in the Kingdom with
gifts Banquets to secure their
cooperation shortly afterwards he
married his first wife whose name has
been lost to history another wise
political move aimed at perpetuating its
Dynasty the young king much like his
father was surrounded by potentially
hostile Nations to his immediate South
lay a rump Gallow Roman State ruled by
former General siagrius right next to
tiagarius the burgundians controlled the
Rhone Valley further south of
isagod-self sway of the kingdom of
Toulouse which encompassed much of
Southern France and part of Northern
Spain finally the alemania group of
German tribes occupied modern-day assass
but unlike his father Clovis were not
simply defend his kingdom he would
muster his allies and relatives amongst
the salience and move on the attack
foreign
have been narrated by the bishop and
historian Gregory of Tor in his history
of the Franks Gary is our main source
about Clovis but unfortunately he
doesn't give us much explanation of his
motives all he writes is that in 486
Clovis Allied himself with his cousins
aragnachar and charik themselves rulers
of small kingdoms and they invaded
surigris's territory the Salient King
challenged his photo battle and siegrius
duly accepted the Barbies crashed in the
Battle of soysor northeast of Paris
during the encounter ragnashar fought
alongside covers while the opportunistic
charik held back his men waiting to
support whoever emerged Victorious there
are no descriptions of this battle but
we can infer the tactics used by Clovis
from later accounts about the Frankish
Warriors written by historian procopius
in the 7th and 8th centuries the Franks
were probably the finest Cavalry in
Europe but in the 5th Century they
fought mostly on foot wielding swords
Shields and axes Frankish soldiers
closed in on the enemy Infantry than
through their battle axes to shatter
their Shields they then launched a
devastating charge rushing the
defenseless forces this is probably how
Clovis and ragnashar crushed siagris at
Sasson the defeated General fled to
Toulouse seeking Refuge with the
visicoths the king Alaric always not too
happy to keep his guest and kicked him
back over to Clovis the Salient King
kept siagra's prisoner for a while and
eventually executed him he then
completed the conquest of his
territories which included the City of
Paris while raiding the land Clovis and
his soldiers pillaged several churches
at this time most Salient Franks were
still Pagan and showed little respect
towards Christianity according to
Gregory during one of these raids the
Frank seized a variable treasure from a
church which contained a vars of
wonderful size and Beauty a local Bishop
asked for the vast to be returned and
Clovis asked his men to comply but one
of them refused it was Frankish
tradition for a king to share half of
the booty with his men thus a foolish
and envious and excitable fellow split
the bows in two with his ax and
insultingly gave to Clovis only one half
of the artifact the king endured the
insult with patience but weeks later he
met the rebellious Soldier again Clovis
snatched his Ax from his hands and threw
it onto the floor as the soldier meant
to pick it up Clovis lifted his own ax
and split the Soldier's head in too some
patience now just before we continue
with today's video I'm going to
interrupt and tell you about one of our
favorite sponsors Squarespace
Squarespace is the absolute best place
to build a website if you need a website
don't even consider anyone else who
thought I need a website for my business
where shall I make it the answer is
Squarespace why because websites are
ridiculously easy to make and feature
Rich with Squarespace look imagine this
situation you know nothing about
websites you love looking at them you
know ones that look good and work quite
well have neat features and now imagine
that you need one of those websites
maybe you want to bring your old
Business website up to date you know so
it doesn't look like it was made back in
2013 or maybe you've got an idea for a
brand new business you've got an idea
for whatever it doesn't matter you
should build it with Squarespace and
that's right Squarespace doesn't just do
blogs which they do beautifully by the
way you can also sell things through
Squarespace which you know is good if
you want to have a business online or
maybe you just want to sell memberships
to your online yoga class or maybe you
just want to do a Blog Squarespace
handles it all plus email campaigns
analytics social Integrations all of
that usual stuff that you would expect
head to squarespace.com for a free trial
when you're ready to launch go to
squarespace.com biographics you're at 10
of your first purchase of a website or a
domain and now back to today's video
so clevers had hit the ground running at
the tender age of 20 the Salient King
had defeated a large room an enclave
conquered Paris and split some heads
along the way not much has been written
about his life in the 480s and early
490s oh we know that sometime between
493 and 499 Clovis took a second wife
named clotild it's not clear if his
first unnamed wife had died in the
meantime or if that separated the second
Mrs Globus was daughter of choparic
brother to gundabar King of the
burgundians clearly the marriage was
politically motivated away to cement an
alliance with another powerful Kingdom
now plottils is unlike her husband was a
Christian and aligned with the Catholic
faith this also set her apart from other
converted Barbarian people such as the
Visigoths who followed the Aryan heresy
to clarify this heresy originated with
preacher aerys of Alexandria Darius did
not believe in the Divinity of Jesus
Christ considered to be a creature of
God on the other hand Catholicism
considers Christ to be an incarnation of
God as a human being since the start of
their marriage Clark Herald tried to
convince Clovis to convert to the one
and true Faith but with little success
when the couple welcomed their firstborn
son ignama clotted insisted upon
baptizing him unfortunately the baby boy
fellow and died which infuriated Clovis
who said if the boy had been dedicated
in the name of my gods he would
certainly have lived the second boy was
born claudimar and also in this case
cartel had him baptized clodma II fell
ill but Gregory of Tor tells us that
clarkell saved him through his prayers
this may have softened closer stance
towards Christianity but for him to
convert it would take a miracle on the
battlefield in 496 Clovis received a
call for help from his colleague Sue
bird king of the ripporian Franks his
people had been erouted by the alemane a
group of German tribes who threatened to
expand Westward Clovis promptly mustered
his army and marched East to clash with
the Alemany at the Battle of zorpark
modern day Germany not far from the
border with Belgium according to Gregory
of tour the alimony initially had the
upper hand seeing his army being
slaughtered Clovis raised his eyes to
Heaven burst into tears and cried Jesus
Christ whom clotted asserts to be the
son of the Living God who art said to
give Aid to those in distress and to
bestow Victory on those who hope in thee
I beseech the glory of thy Aid with the
vow that if thou Wilt grant me victory
over these enemies well we'll just cut
the quote right there because according
to Gregory Clovis went on monologuing
his prayers for a whole 136-word
paragraph I guess he wasn't that busy
being in the middle of a battle while
his men were being slayed but apparently
his crive help did the trick as soon as
he invoked Christ's help the tide turned
the Alemany turned their back and began
to disperse in flight and when they saw
that their King was killed they
submitted to the Dominion of Clovis the
victory over the al-amani is Undisputed
as it was confirmed by a letter of
congratulations sent to Clovis by
Theodore King of the ostrogoth the man
miraculous part well you could draw your
own conclusions about that contemporary
historians such as the earlier quoted
Professor Friedman believed that Gregory
may have inserted this version of events
to draw parallels between Clovis and a
Roman emperor Constantine Constantine
converted to Christianity after his
victory at the Battle of milvian bridge
in 312 A.D and so did Clovis after his
victory it's your pick on Christmas Day
496 Clovis and 3 000 of his soldiers
were baptized at Rheem by Bishop Remy
according to another source the
chronicle of Saint Dennis yet another
miracle took place during the ceremony a
dove a lighter snow descended bearing in
his Beaker vial of holy oil a delicious
odor exhaled from it the holy Bishop
took the vial and suddenly the dove
vanished transported with joy at the
sight of this notable Miracle the king
renounced Satan
surely Clovis wanted to renounce Satan
but his conversion also bore significant
political advantages after his initial
Wars of Conquest his main political
adversaries such as the visigoth
belonged to the arraigned Faith while
potential allies such as the Eastern
Roman Empire opposed the heresy in fact
following the ceremony at Rheem Clovis
received a letter from anastasius
Emperor Constantinople appointing him as
a friend Patrician and counselor of the
Romans we shall see later how this
friendship would prove fruitful for the
time being Clovis I would only get
involved in the internal affairs of The
Burgundian Kingdom sometime before the
year 500 A.D King gundabar of the
burgundians had killed two of his
brothers gundamar and kilparik who I
will remind you was clovis's
father-in-law gundabar now vied for
total power against his last surviving
brother go to Gasol a rivalry which
erupted in Civil War in the year 500. go
to gessel asked for clovis's Alliance
promising an annual tribute to the
Franks helped him kill or expel gundabar
naturally Clovis was happy to intervene
against the man who had killed clotild's
dad the saliens marched into Burgundian
land which led gundabar to believe that
the Franks were aiming to swallow his
kingdom wholesale the worried King sent
a message to God again to the effect of
dude how about we put aside our
differences and joined forces against
our common foe yeah to which goriaso
replied with something like yeah man
sounds good all right the three armies
met by the river ush near Dijon at this
point Godzilla made uttered something to
the effect of ah sorry bro and then he
revealed his true Allegiance teaming up
with Clovis to charge against gundabar
the Allied armies crushed gundabar's
forces and the King himself had to
escape to the safety of avignor a
heavily fortified City in the south at
this point got to guess a warmly thanked
Clovis promised him part of The
Burgundian territory and left the
campaign his priority was to Stage a
[ __ ] in gundabar's capital vien just
south of Lyon but Globus was not one for
giving up a good fight and he pursued
gundabad Avenue his forces alone however
were not enough to break through the
city's defenses The Siege dragged onto a
sale mace which was broken only through
deceit one of gundabar's advisors
pretended to defect to the Frankish side
promising Clovis an annual tribute if he
lifted The Siege Clovis accepted the
deal and returned to his kingdom leaving
it to the two brothers to sort out their
issues it appears that gundabar only
paid the first installment of the
tribute by the way with the Franks now
gone gundabar was free to besiege vienne
in 501 the city fell and godigessa was
killed
after The Burgundian Adventure Clovis
came into conflict with Visigoths of
King Alaric II according to One Source
the salience and the Visigoths may have
been embroiled in a short war already in
498 which had no significant impact on
their borders war broke out again in
507. it's not clear why but according to
Gregory of Tor this may have been a
religious conflict Clovis wanted to
protect Catholic Bishops who were being
harassed by Alaric and Aryan King
theodoric of the ostrogoth also of Aryan
Faith wished to intervene alongside
Alaric you see his daughter theodoga was
married to Alaric how could he not fight
alongside his son-in-law on the other
hand his wife was Aldo flader sister of
Clovis how could he fight against his
brother-in-law Sink of the awkward
silence as a Christmas lunch eventually
this impasse was solved by the Eastern
Roman Emperor anastasius the emperor had
a policy of supporting Catholic monarchs
against Aryan ones as theodoric owed
Alliance to Anastasia it was simply
ordered not to intervene so Alaric had
to fight alone unlike Clovis who forged
alliances with his old faux gundabar and
with clauderick the son of his old
friend seabert of the rapporian Franks
the opposing sides clashed at Fourier
close to Poitier in central France as
usual Gregory is scant on details
telling us that neither the Goths had
fled as was their custom which is a bit
unfair as the Goths were renowned
Warriors but they were Aryans while
Gregory was Catholic so he might have
been a bit
in the aftermath of the battle Alaric
was slain while Clovis and his buddy
clodorig sees Bordeaux to lose and
Angela Gregory gives us a realistic
account of this later Siege the lord
gave him Clovis such Grace that the
walls fell down of their own accord when
he gazed at them then he drove the Goths
out and brought the city under his own
dominion in the meanwhile The Burgundian
allies had opened another front
besieging the city of Al in 508. only
then theodoric was able to intervene he
invaded or what his modern day Provence
and kicked out the begunians at the end
of the war the Visigoths had retained
control of septomania the western part
of France's Mediterranean Coast as well
as their Spanish territories but the
vast province of Aquitaine had been
annexed by Clovis to his ever-expanding
Frankish Kingdom the fate of the
Visigoths came with another award
directly from Emperor anastasius the
appointment of Clovis as Roman console
after defeating the visigoth Clovis
established his capital in Paris with
little threats coming from outside
Clovis turned his bellicose attention to
his allies his first goal was to absorb
the kingdom a reporion Franks to do so
he conspired with clodoric son of
siegabut convincing him to kill his own
father and inherit the Kingdom clodoric
agreed and had seek but assassinated he
then sent a message to Clovis asking him
to send some of his men to collect
Super's treasure when clovis's envoys
showed up one of them lifted his ax and
split clodorix skull into the crafty
Clovis then erode out to meet The
reporion Chieftains to give them the bad
news that both their King and their
prince had been slain by Brilliance
reportedly his words were I am in no way
an accomplishing these Deeds for I
cannot shed the blood of my kinsfolk but
since the deed was done he continued how
about the ripporians except him as king
and they did raising him on their
Shields next on his Hit List were
chararic and ragnachar if you remember
these were cousins to Clovis who had
supported him in his first war against
CR well ragnatar at least as chiarik had
sat on the fence the very end initially
Clovis forced chiarik and his son into
priesthood thus nullifying their
military threat but herarick's son
surely not the sharpest tool in the shed
spread the word that he would eventually
meet out revenge on Clovis naturally
Jaric senior and Junior had their hands
chopped off Clovis absorbed his kingdom
and moved on to ragnachar Clovis sent
envoys to bribe some of ragnachar's
Chieftains the dupes didn't realize that
these precious gifts were actually only
gold-plated and they switched sides
inviting Clovis to invade ragnarchar's
Kingdom the treacherous Chief Danes then
reassured ragnachar and his brother
Rickard that Clovis Army was a weak
competitor to theirs the two brothers
went to war confidently but their forces
were crushed by the saliens they were
then captured and brought before Clovis
with their hands tied behind their backs
according to Gregory cliver's berated
them for allowing themselves to be taken
captive and immediately killed them with
his ax the final named victim of
clovis's spree was another brother of
he was assassinated at Moore's modern
day Belgium with his kingdom annexed by
Clovis what is most surprising is that
after this massacre of his own cousins
the Frankish King had the cheek to
complain about his loneliness woe to me
who have remained as a stranger among
foreigners and have none of my Kinsmen
to give me Aid if adversity comes
Clovis would not have to complain about
Solitude for much longer in November of
511 the Frankish King died of unknown
causes as perprankish customers Dominion
was split equally amongst his four Sons
a decision which led to a period of
instability and struggle but I'd like to
focus on clovis's long-term Legacy his
methods may have been questionable
albeit in line with Frankish custom his
results however have been exceptional
starting as the teenage king of a small
Frankish State he had succeeded in
uniting most of Western northern France
as well as annexing large territories
east of the Rhine he had created a
stable state which combined laws and
customs from the Roman German and
Christian Traditions he had founded a
dynasty the mayor of Indians that was
destined to rule for almost three
centuries French Scholars artists and
politicians alike later considered him
to be the Founding Father of the French
Nation the quote General shardigold to
me the history of France begins with
Clovis
foreign